[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver
pour une émission qu'on va consacrer
comme vous pouviez l'imaginer sans doute
à ce choc des élections régionales et à
la façon dont et reconfigurer le paysage
politique en particulier à droite et au
rassemblement national nous avons pour
cela deux éminents observateurs qui sont
aussi deux des plus importants sondeurs
de la place de paris bonsoir frédéric
dabi vous êtes directeur général de
l'ifop
et puis emmanuel rivière est là aussi
bon soir emmanuel ravi de vous retrouver
après cette soirée mémorable d'hier sur
figaro live vous êtes le directeur des
études politiques de kantar public
alors on va s'intéresser à un
enseignement politique de cette élection
mais d'abord comme je tiens deux
sondeurs sous la main j'ai envie de vous
poser la question finalement avec le
recul est ce que vous vous êtes plantés
sur cette élection ou pas vous les
instituts de sondage des manuels on aura
plus de recul avec le temps il le faudra
d'ailleurs parce que de toute évidence
il ya quelque chose qui techniquement a
fait déjouer les sondages
historiquement on a la mémoire de la
difficulté des sondages à appréhender le
score du rassemblement national est
plutôt dans le sens de la
sous-estimation en fait c'est je crois
qu'on peut lire quelque chose qui a été
résolue il ya bien longtemps déjà grâce
notamment au fait qu'avec que les
sondages par internet on ne l'a plus de
sincérité sur ce point mme eliane son
estimation parce qu'il ya des gens qui
votent rassemblement national et qui ne
vous le disent pas forcément c'est plus
tellement le cas aujourd'hui
par contre est quelque chose qui reste
qu'à toujours été d'ailleurs un sujet
c'est la juste estimation de la
participation électorale
c'est très très compliqué d'arriver à
faire la part des choses entre les gens
qui nous disent oui bien sûr je vais
aller voter et qui ne le font pas quand
on est sur un mode un taux de
participation aussi accidents tels que
celui qu'on a observé hier la semaine
dernière or il se trouve que ce
différentiel de participation
probablement n'était pas neutre dans la
distribution des voix autrement dit ceux
qui ne sont pas allés voter sans doute
n'aurait pas voter s'il y était allé
comme ceux qui sont allés voter est en
fête et voulons pas dit parce que c'est
difficile de répondre non je préfère le
barbecue dominical à mon devoir civique
frédéric dabi c'est ça qui sert j'ai des
regrets d'être complètement d'accord
avec ce que vient de dire emmanuel
rivière c'est tout à fait ça c'est vrai
que pendant très longtemps on les
sondeurs avaient des soucis avec le un
vote fn cacher je me souviens quelques
jours après le 21 avril 2002 l'institut
auquel j'appartenais cesse avait fait
une enquête de deuxième tour
on n'avait que 8 % des gens deux jours
après l'interview qui disait j'ai voté
jean marie le pen le 21 avril 2002
n'avaient cette sous-estimation 716 16,8
un petit peu plus que jospin certains
s'en souviennent je pense là c'est vrai
que ce qui se passe c'est qu'on grâce au
vote par internet grâce aux meilleures
constitution de vote on n'a plus du tout
ce ce problème il est arrivé son camp
nou nous on veuille que les sondeurs et
surestimé le vote fn c'est le cas par
exemple au départemental de 2015 mais là
clairement le l'instrument était
complètement bouleversé par sa part 7 /
abstention traditionnellement les gens
aimaient tous expriment faiblement une
abstention des camps l'abstention est
raisonnable quand elle est faible voire
à une élection présidentielle
ou quand elle ne dépasse pas 50% on
arrive à compenser la absolument pas et
c'est vrai que quand je regarde la
production de l'ifop pourra s'y
rattachent et nous avons bien estimé le
rapport de force dans deux régions île
de france corse c'est maigre
malheureusement mais ce sont des régions
où le fn où le fn était faible dans les
autres régions le fn a été asséché si je
puis dire par cette très forte
abstention et l'estimation était
mauvaise même si et je les écris je les
dis les sondages donc à montrer que les
sortants s'en sortait bien que les
sortants avaient la cote et que quasi
aucun sortant a par renaud muselier
était dans une difficulté apparente mais
ce qui est très intéressant
on avait eu le même phénomène aux
élections municipales dans les
nombreuses villes où il faut pas vais à
travailler nous avions un petit peu
surestimé le vote des listes pour le
rassemblement national
et là aussi au premier tour il y avait
eu 57 % d'abstention il faut maintenant
non plus cherché du fn cacher mais des
abstentionnistes gachassin nouveau né
fille qu'on va essayer de relever
notamment dans l'est pour les scrutins
futurs pas la présidentielle mais si on
dépasse 25 30 40 % à la prescience s est
pas impossible compte tenu de ce cycle
mortifère ça ce serait un vrai défi la
règle du jeu on va revenir dans quelques
minutes un on va s'interroger pour
savoir pourquoi est ce que les électeurs
du rassemblement national se sont
abstenus ainsi il sans forcément le dire
aux instituts de sondage mais commençons
par la droite
de gouvernement 3 président réélu hier
soir sont plus ou moins officiellement
en lice pour l'élection présidentielle
et xavier bertrand valérie pécresse
laurent wauquiez alors compte tenu de ce
que les lecteurs à droite et les
situations de la france et le rapport de
force et ce qui en a un qui a plus de
chance que les autres
on va vous poser la question messieurs
mais je vous propose auparavant de
réentendre quelques instants le discours
quasi présidentielle de xavier bertrand
hier soir après sa victoire ce soir je
veux m'adresser directement à cette
france que l'on refuse de voir que l'on
refuse d'entendre et qui s'est abstenu
ces deux dimanches
c'est le cri du coeur de la france qui
chaque jour travaillent et qui pourtant
n'arrivent plus à joindre les deux bouts
c'est le cri de la france à qui l'on
demande toujours plus d'efforts et qui
le reçoit en retour que mépris ou
indifférence et bien c'est pas facile de
savoir qui est de ses trois président
réélu le lemieux cap et pour 2022 parce
que d'abord ils ont tous les trois gagné
et puis ils ont des positionnements qui
sont assez différents et qui sont
semble-t-il ont tous été gagnant valérie
pécresse plutôt centriste laurent
wauquiez plutôt droite solide on va dire
et puis xavier bertrand plus dans une
registre populaire alors qu'est ce qui à
votre avis est le mieux en phase avec
les attentes de l'électorat de droite en
régie d'ailleurs qui sont très liés à
leur territoire d'élection respectives
mais c'est vrai que ça les a qualifiés
tous les trois si je regarde notre
baromètre le baromètre politique du
figaro magazine
alors on vient de dire ce qu'on pouvait
penser des sondages et des réserves
enfin voilà le baromètre du figaro
magazine a toujours mis à cette période
de l'année
le futur président de la république
parmi
les premiers de son de son classement
est d'ailleurs exactement cinq ans les
quatre ténors de la campagne
présidentielle de 2017 macron le pen
mélenchon et fillon étaient tous parmi
les dix premiers est à peu près la navy
et bertrand est le seul qui soit à ce
niveau là aujourd'hui
donc c'est lui c'est lui qui se sent
mieux placé valérie pécresse est tout
près laurent wauquiez un petit peu
d'écart et quand on analyse dans ce même
baromètre
la structure on voit que xavier bertrand
koch davantage de cas c'est à dire qu'il
a l'oreille des sympathisants du
rassemblement national ce qui est aussi
le cas de laurent wauquiez mais il ne
déplaît pas aux sympathisants la
république en marche les gens qui se
classe au centre de l'échiquier
politique
ce qui n'est pas le cas de laurent
wauquiez et valérie pécresse un
positionnement un peu plus entre exemple
pour l'instant et parce que toujours pas
se poser un moment la question de bons
candidats de premier tour traits
saillants sur aston le sujet ou de
second tour
rassembleur pour l'instant xavier
bertrand est celui qui compte le plus de
gaz
je partage plutôt cet avis est vrai que
les 3 c3 président réélu il ya pas qu il
n'y a pas que il ya eu un grand chelem
des présidents sortants de gauche comme
de droite ont en tête à mon avis le
mécanisme de 2004 2006 ségolène royal
qui symbolise la victoire de la gauche
aux élections régionales qui bat jean
pierre raffarin pas candidate à te poser
quelques semaines après devient
absolument incontournable dans le cadre
de la primaire socialiste à venir là
c'est vrai que quand je regarde les
enquêtes de l'ifop alors c'est un autre
baromètre c'est une fois fiducial pour
paris match et sud radio la question est
moins dure que celle que la vôtre
puisque la hausse et une cote d'avenir
si je ne me trompe pas face à des
questions plus difficiles on a aussi
cette hiérarchie un petit peu moins
saillantes avantage xavier bertrand qui
a une structure de popularité qui sort
de l'électorat de droite il est plutôt
assez bon chez les ouvriers dans les
catégories populaires
il est fort à droite mais qu à
quasi-égalité auprès des sympathisants
de droite avec françois baroin ou
valérie pécresse mais c'est vrai que je
pense que il a un avantage très fort par
rapport aux 2 présidents convient de
citer il est candidat
il s'est déclaré moi je suis frappée
c'est pas mon choix
ah je pense que c'était le bon choix
puisque on a vu qu'il a un peu crantée
dans les enquêtes d'intentions de vote
sept qu'on a fait avec le figaro et lci
le mettais à 15 16%
ce qui était un socle intéressant le
seul à battre très largement marine le
pen et c'est vrai que les trois des
trois discours celui qui a peut-être été
le plus impactant qui était le plus
présidentiable vous le disais il n'a pas
parlé de normes administratives comme
laurent wauquiez il a été peut-être plus
pénétrer si je puis dire de sa tâche et
de sens de sa mission si je puis dire
que valérie pécresse est clairement il
ya marqué des points on a réalisé une
enquête avec lci et le figaro
aux quelques minutes après les résultats
du premier tour je n'aime pas trop cette
enquête à chaud parce que il ya un temps
de digestion de l'opinion publique on
voit que xavier bertrand et de soldes
qui apparaît pour une majorité de
français est très fort à droite comme le
meilleur candidat mais entre la droite
mais en même temps emmanuel rivière le
ce qui est épatant
pour lui c'est que l'on mette leur
envolée dans ce trio quand on sait d'où
il revient quand on se souvient combien
il était parti quasiment en exil dans
cette région c'était l'homme de droite
le plus détesté de france c'est quand
même un bon retour non j'ai partagé la
photo à l'instant t des positions
respectives
si on regarde le film la position de vos
amis bertrand et dans les six premiers
du classement depuis un moment déjà
laurent wauquiez revient de loin il ya
une espèce de dynamique qui se fait
autour de autour de lui et qui peut être
portée ou pas au delà en fonction des
circonstances
la démonstration qu'a fait laurent
wauquiez est assez nette en fait il a
pris un positionnement très axé sur les
questions de sécurité et peut se
prévaloir d'avoir stoppé le
rassemblement national dans sa région
sur ces thématiques là du coup son
devenir dans la compétition
présidentielle dépendra un peu de là où
on circule danger notamment dans cet
électorat
de droite et de centre-droit qui ne veut
pas du rassemblement national est ce que
c'est de ce côté là où est ce que il y
aura une lassitude à l'égard des
d'emmanuel macron à c'est d'ailleurs
quelque chose sur quoi devront se
positionner les trois crs qu'à un moment
leur électorat voudra plutôt quelqu'un
qui rompent avec le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron ou qui stoppe une
progression du rassemblement national et
de ce point de vue là les positions
bougé hier je vous pose nous vous posons
part dans la question chers internautes
les résultats de ces régionales vont ils
faciliter le choix d'un candidat pour la
droite bien vous êtes 65 % à considérer
que non gisèle nous dit tout dépendra si
ce soir gagner une primaire ou s'ils
font une sélection en interne ou bien
s'il n'y a pas de sélection du tout vous
savez que xavier bertrand a dit que quoi
qu'il arrive il serait candidat
cela va être la guerre des ego se
lamente daniel tandis que babineau
estime que les sondages sont des
photographies mais que plusieurs
facteurs comme une abstention massive
peuvent changer la donne ça c'est
vraiment là on l'a appris dans ces
élections régionales
il ne faut pas faire l'erreur de calquer
les prévisions de la présidentielle sur
les résultats des régionales nous dit
jean paul et puis françois qui ajoute il
y en a plusieurs qui veulent se
présenter aux présidentielles car les
résultats aux régionales était très bon
mais ça ne veut rien dire
la région et le pays c'est différent
c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas obligé d'être
président de région pour se présenter à
l'elysée
et si certains avaient oublié le patron
des sénateurs l air au sénat lui nous
l'a rappelé ce matin écouter bruno
retailleau
les régionales ne peuvent pas être un
système de primaires voilà tant que tout
le monde peut michel barnier comme moi
de prétendre vous êtes tous dissipés
bien sûr à une primaire c'est toujours
candidat a pris d'abord oui les
primaires et il faut une prime ou vers
l'ailleurs cette image et s'exprimer
ouverte je la souhaite pas ce que c'est
c'est un choix c'est dire aux gens
allaient participer
voilà on se plaint d'une trop faible
participation
donc le vote en démocratie c'est le
meilleur moyen de départager les uns et
les autres
frédéric dabi est ce que les trois
présidents élus dont on parle valérie
pécresse xavier bertrand laurent
wauquiez connaissent juste leur quart
d'heure de célébrité est là et dans une
semaine
les autres viennent dans la course ou
est ce que des gens comme retailleau
barnier prennent un peu de retard en
n'étant pas président de région réélu
c'est pas une question de présidence de
région pour bruno retailleau et même
pour michel barnier c'est une question
de visibilité c'est une question de
popularité c'est qu'elles sont même de
notoriété auprès des français
je partage l'avis de bruno retailleau
qu'est ce que nous a appris la la
séquence électorale depuis 2010 est
celle essais d'étanchéité absolue entre
la sphère politique locale où les partis
de l'ancien monde parti socialiste
républicain puisqu'on parle
d'aujourd'hui même si ni xavier bertrand
ni valérie pécresse
ils appartiennent à cette formation
domine nettement hélas sa politique
nationale ou pour l'instant ici et
maintenant
un sondage n'est pas une prédiction ça a
été bien dit par babineau
on ne reste en piste et par le duel
macron le pen et même quand on regarde
le troisième homme si la tendance à
s'effondrer jean luc mélenchon on voit
qu'il tient mieux que la france est
soumise qui a eu des résultats
extrêmement faible au premier tour des
élections régionales mais là où pour new
retail ou peut-être s'illusionne c'est
qu'on arrivait beaucoup d' enquête
auprès d'électeurs de droite de
sympathisants de droite la primaire de
2016 reste un véritable trauma et donc
il ya un an quand même un rejet d'une
procédure qui viserait à départager des
candidats dans le cadre d'une primaire
ouverte façon novembre 2016 et pour la
première raison qui est invoquée les
peut-être inexactes par rapport au
scénario de 2017 est ce qu a connues
françois fillon c'est que elle provoque
des déchirures des divisions irréparable
à droite et n'oublions pas que dans la
conscience du peuple de droite il ya
quand même ce trauma depuis les années
chirac chaban jusqu'aux années fillon
copé pour parler de la suite de cette
division de la droite et c'est vrai que
xavier bertrand qui cherchent à enjamber
à tout prix un processus de désignation
mais peut-être les gens devant le fait
accompli mais aura de ce point de vue là
peut-être le soutien est sympa de centre
droite c'est emmanuel rivière on
n'évitera pas le le bain de sang façon
bagarre d'astérix chez les leaders de la
droite pour se départager parce que si
xavier bertrand veut pas aller à la
primaire si les autres y tienne il n'y a
pas de solution
effectivement c'est d'ailleurs une des
tactiques xavier bertrand c'est d'avoir
à ce point crantée sa position presque
une manière de s'interdire d'aller
d'aller à la primaire qui ne leur est
pas une si mauvaise solution c'est
intéressant que dans les enquêtes de
frédéric les électeurs est un si mauvais
souvenir de la primaire mais dans la
défaite de françois fillon ni prêt pour
grand chose au lendemain de la primaire
dans nos premières enquêtes d'intentions
de vote ils étaient 28 % des soucis pas
longtemps après sur les questions de
programmatiquement ya quand même eu un
gros accident de parcours qui a
strictement rien à voir avec la primaire
et donc on est resté sur l'idée que les
primaires c'est une mauvaise manière de
désigner des candidats sur deux
situations un peu atypique toujours est
il que à gauche comme à droite
d'ailleurs le fait d'avoir des poids
lourds qui disent votre primaire je n'en
veux pas je n'irai pas l'un jean luc
mélenchon qui a fait
consultation eu beaucoup d'effet dégâts
dans l'opinion et l'autre xavier
bertrand qui dit c'est mon élection qui
validera ma candidature sont un moyen de
neutraliser le primaire et donc
effectivement ça ce sont des facteurs de
division et ça va être plus compliqué
d'imposer une primaire parce que le fait
du paysage politique tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui
morcelée en au moins quatre pôles c'est
que contrairement à 1988
contrairement en 1995 ce n'est pas le
premier tour qui peut servir de
primaires le premier tour disqualifie le
camp qui les divisent et parce qu'ils ne
se retrouvent pas au second
du fait de la dispersion des voix de son
camp je propose de terminer cette partie
de notre débat avec le point de vue de
nicole ou plutôt le souhait de nicole
quand on se fait élire un poste on y
reste jusqu'au bout cela s'est pas
complètement certain en tout cas pour
xavier bertrand il n'a pas fait mystère
de ses ambitions nationales